Welcome back to human emotion.
Um,
today we're going to continue the second part of our discussion as to whether
emotions are evolutionarily evolved and we're going to do so today by focusing
even deeper on this issue of evolution and emotion.
So we're going to look at this question of our emotions,
really part of our early evolutionarily,
uh,
history and origins by doing the following today.
As you can see on the roadmap,
we'll talk about the evolution of emotion,
the principle of cultural universality,
a functional approach to different kinds of emotions wrapped up by our takeaway
questions and expert interview today.
So let's start with evolution and emotion.
So here you can see here is the reminder from our last lecture,
there were five big take home ideas to grasp behind evolutionary theory.
This included gene replication,
selection pressures,
natural selection pressures,
sexual selection pressures,
and group selection pressures.
Okay,
so when we think about the sort of evolutionary approach to motion Paul Ekman,
who's one of the sort of a founders behind this thinking,
uh,
he thought about the question for us of what is an emotion from this
perspective?
And from an evolutionary perspective,
he posited six features of what an emotion is.
So first he would say emotions are brief.
They happen in four to five seconds.
Quick.
Second,
emotions are unbidden.
He would say they are involuntary.
Emotions are not in our control.
That they're simply something that happens to you.
Third emotions are what he called cross species phenomena.
So you see similar behaviors and experiences and other primate species.
Fourth,
emotions are coherent.
So we talked earlier about emotions,
having multiple components,
right?
Expressions,
uh,
experiences of emotion internally and physiological responses.
He would say these three components of emotion work together and come online
together.
They cohere.
Fifth emotions are fast.
So there's a quick onset to,
there are whole emotional system.
Sometimes emotions can sort of get online within even milliseconds.
So it doesn't take long.
Once you're sort of a brain registers at an emotion should occur.
It happens fast.
And finally,
the sixth feature of what is an emotion Pollock women would say is that it has
an automatic appraisal or evaluation.
So that,
um,
in other words,
the appraisal is your evaluation of the world and that this is something that
accompanies emotion and can happen very fast.
So these are the six features of what is an emotion from an evolutionary
perspective on as discussed by Paul Ekman.
Okay.
So now we've talked a little bit about what an emotion is from an evolutionary
perspective.
Now I want to turn to this notion of cultural universality.
So this is the idea that emotions are evolved and because they're evolved,
we should see them similarly present across different populations and cultures.
So here's a first example.
Um,
that's evidence of this idea that emotions are cultural universal.
So what we see it really interesting early work done,
um,
suggest here that emotion expressions are evident even among the [inaudible]
congenitally blind.
So children who are born blind,
independent of culture,
as you can see here,
show expressions even at an early age.
So here we see a young child smiling.
Um,
there's also evidence by Matsumoto.
I'm showing that Olympians who are blind,
when they have won a gold medal,
they will also show expressions of happiness.
Or if they lost expressions of sadness or grief.
So this seems to be something that's hardwired in us to express emotions and
that their co a universal across cultures,
they're not something we necessarily have to learn through seeing other people
express emotions.
A second example,
um,
that was really pushed forth by Paul Ekman,
uh,
in his New Guinea study,
which we'll talk about in a minute,
is this idea of co emotion,
emotions being cultural universal in so far as we see emotion expressions
consistent across westernized and non Westernized cultures.
So here he went to study,
um,
the tribal people of New Guinea,
to look at whether or not indeed they experienced,
um,
emotions in the same way as non western individuals.
So here what [inaudible] did is he took it across cultural approach to
understanding emotion by studying the preindustrial foray Treisman of New
Guinea,
uh,
just north of Australia.
And here he observed that members of this isolated culture could reliably
identify expressions of emotion and photographs of people from cultures they
weren't even familiar with.
So on this evidence,
Paul Ekman concluded that expressions of emotion,
uh,
must be sort of basic,
this sort of evolutionary phenomena that's hardwired in us from birth and that
they should be similarly seen across cultures.
So let's look at some of the data that he did in his famous New Guinea study.
So the goal of his research was to examine if basic emotion expressions are
culturally universal.
And his method,
as we just spoke about,
was to travel to the non Westernized tribe in New Guinea.
And there were two parts to his study.
So part one that you see here is that he showed a series of six basic emotion
expressions and asked the new Guinea tribes people to choose which emotion in
these pictures best matched an emotion word.
So to pick out which kind of emotion word fit the picture and it looks something
like this.
So they would see a picture of someone expressing an emotion and they'd be given
a list of emotions from a,
of the six basic emotions.
And they would be asked to select which emotion best match the picture.
So you can see here the correct answer would be selecting happiness to match
that expression right there.
Or perhaps they saw an expression more like this and they were asked to again
indicate from these six basic emotion words,
uh,
translated to their own native language,
which best match the picture like discussed.
Um,
like I said,
there were two parts of this study.
So on the second part,
um,
individuals are asked to listen to vignettes or stories of individuals
experiencing different kinds of emotional life events.
And from these vignettes,
they were asked to pick the emotion photo that best match the story.
So for example,
they'd be told the story,
a story about someone who experienced the time,
um,
where they saw a snake and they were feeling very scared or fearful and from
these six pictures to pick which photograph best matched that person's
experience.
So you would pick the bottom photo in the middle.
So this was to try to get away from just using words to match photos,
but instead to try to use the expressions themselves to match the stories.
Um,
if you're interested in learning more about Paul Ackman's research,
both this early New Guinea study that was one of the pioneering studies for the
ice idea of cultural universality.
Um,
then you can refer here to his book called emotions revealed.
Okay.
So we've talked a little bit about cultural universality or how many of our
emotions are sort of hardwired.
And thus we see them present across all kinds of cultures,
both westernized and even non industrialized,
non Western countries like New Guinea.
So now we're going to turn to this idea of a functional approach to emotions.
And what I mean by this is that emotions are thought of as being functional,
so functional in the sense that they help us to achieve our goals and it's
important that such motions be functional in order to help us,
uh,
sort of meet our survival goals or needs.
So let's turn now to this functional approach on emotions.
So here we're going to go through the six basic emotions and walk through the
features of what way they are functional.
So we'll talk about fear
followed by sadness,
then discussed anger,
happiness.
And last but not least,
surprise.
So let's start with fear and do a functional analysis of fear from an
evolutionary perspective.
So here we see fear and what we think of from fear of,
so this is our functional analysis of fear,
is there's gotta be some kind of recurring evolutionary situation that elicits
or triggers sphere.
So this would be hearing cues associated with a Predator or some sort of threat
to one's survival,
the appraisal or thoughts behind fear or that this is unsafe,
this is dangerous or please don't attack.
Um,
and the behavior would be this kind of flight or fight reaction,
focus more on the flight of getting away from that situation as quickly as
possible.
Our physiological response would include increased blood flow to the periphery
as well as increased oxygen volume.
And what's the function of this?
Again,
we said emotions are functional.
They're supposed to be there to perform some sort of goal for us or aid in our
survival.
Well here,
the function of,
um,
of an emotion like fear would be to help you escape the Predator,
to sort of ensure your safety or if need be defend for yourself.
And you can see this as all sort of supported by,
you know,
evaluating the situation is unsafe.
Having this sort of physiological mobile it mobilization to sort of get away as
quickly as possible.
So let's fear,
let's now turn to sadness and do a same or similar functional approach.
So if we look at sadness using the same sort of schematic we just did with fear,
the recurrent evolutionary situation would be losing something of value.
So it could be a person,
it could be an object or it could be a place.
The appraisal behind sadness would be,
I miss,
I miss that thing or I need comfort behavior.
Often associated with sadness is motor slowing and retardation or just a general
withdraw,
kind of stepping away from things that you would normally engage in.
Um,
we see changes in our physiological can,
uh,
sort of repertoire.
We see increased heart rate and breathing and often we see increased activity of
the lack of remote glands associated with crying or having tears and people
often wonder,
why do we feel sad?
What,
what is the function?
Why do we have it in the first place?
Um,
and it's really interesting because sadness is important for us.
It's critical to our survival goals.
So it helps us feel motivated to avoid future losses and change circumstances
around us to make sure that that's the case.
And importantly,
sadness,
elicit social support from others.
So when you need comforting or you need help,
um,
expressions and experiences of sadness pull for other people to get close to
you.
What about disgust?
So discusses an emotion most of us don't enjoy experiencing,
but we have it there for a reason.
So the recurrent evolutionary situation behind discussed is encountering some
potential poison or contaminant and there's these universal listers,
cross culture that seemed to elicit disgust.
And most of us such as feces,
urine,
blood vomit,
flesh,
all those good things there.
Most of us feel disgust when we see them.
Um,
the appraisal behind discussed is that this is unhealthy or this is unsafe for
me.
And behaviors include trying to repel or kind of distance oneself from the
disgusting stimuli and it has a very characteristic facial expression.
You can see in this young man,
um,
what we see physiologically as this Vegas nerve stimulation that's involved in
digestion.
And the function again is to repel a substance away from the body.
So I talk about universal,
universal,
illicit or is of disgust.
And here's an example of one that's used in a lot of studies.
Um,
hopefully most of you feel some discussing this photo.
If you don't,
then you are an interesting evolutionary case.
It seems that we have this instinctive kind of discussed instinct and David
Pizarro,
uh,
from Cornell University has done a lot of work on discuss using stimulii like
this and we'll be speaking with us about his work later in the course.
So I promise I won't show you that picture again of the teeth and we'll turn now
to anger.
So we've all felt anger at different times.
And why do we have anger in the first place?
What goal does it serve for us?
So the recurrent evolutionary situation with anger is really you're,
you're uh,
trying to,
uh,
sort of pursue a goal and it's forwarded or its stymied or someone's doing
something that's getting in your way and that you don't approve of.
So you,
the thoughts that would go through your head or appraisals would be,
you are in the way of what I want.
I'm going to attack you.
You're doing something wrong.
And here again,
we have this fight or fight reaction here,
focused more on the fight part of it and what you see physiologically as
increased blood flow and increase the oxygen volume,
sort of mobilizing your body to attack.
And the function of anger.
It's important for us to have anger as well.
It helps us confront and eliminate a person or thing in the way of our goal or
someone or something that may be committing some sort of moral wrongdoing.
And what about happiness?
It's something that's really interesting to all of us.
We see modern society almost obsessed with pursuing happiness and experiencing
even more happiness.
So why do we care so much about happiness?
Why might it be actually very critical for our survival.
So here we see happiness.
So the recurrent evolutionary situation is a situation in which there's
potential rewards and opportunities that are available to us.
Could be a food,
could be a potential mating partner or,
or some other resource.
And the thoughts are appraisals that go on in our minds are things like,
I like that or I want that.
And also it's a really pro social kind of emotion.
So,
um,
we're thinking things like I'm friendly,
I want to connect with that person around me.
So we had behaviors that include incentives seeking.
So trying to seek out and get rewards in the environment or to show other people
that you have in more affiliative orientation,
you want to be part of their group,
you want to connect with them.
And we see different kinds of physiological things go on in our body when we
feel happy.
On the one hand we might see increased sort of cardiovascular or physiological
arousal,
um,
that will help us get the energy to go obtain that award or goal.
Um,
and we might also see increased vagal tone,
which we'll talk more about later in the course as a sort of physiological sort
of,
um,
substrate or correlate of these kind of feelings that connect us to other
people.
I want to keep us close to them.
The function of happiness is to help motivate energy to acquire and attain
potential rewards or to establish relationships with other people,
either friendships or romantic relationships as well as relationships with close
family members.
Last but not least is this funny emotion of surprise and it's something that we
see has been built in us for many,
many,
many years in our evolutionary history.
So the recurrent situation here is something unexpected happens.
Um,
and you think things like,
well,
what is that?
Or look over there.
Um,
behaviors include energy mobilization,
increased attentional focus to kind of see what is happening in environment and
what exactly has just changed.
Um,
you see increased blood flow,
increased oxygen volume,
sort of your body sort of getting mobilized.
It's alerted to things going on around it and it's trying to gauge what is it
and how should one respond.
So the function of it is to help you evaluate when there's unexpected changes in
your environment and to readily and quickly re adapt to these new circumstances.
So we've gone through the six basic emotions,
but I want to leave one here,
which wasn't on the original list,
which is this emotion of jealousy.
I'm sort of as a teaser for something we're going to talk about later in the
course.
Then we get to the ideas of sex and love.
Um,
and here it's interesting because if you want to learn about jealousy,
it's really important and actually incredibly necessary to our sexual survival.
So David Bus wrote a book called the Dangerous Passion,
why jealousy is as necessary as love and sex.
So we'll talk later in the course about just why it's important to actually feel
jealous,
how many of our romantic relationships might be threatened if we didn't feel
jealousy in the first place.
Now finally we're going to turn to our takeaway questions from today.
And these include three questions as as normal.
So the three takeaway questions for today,
our first,
what is Edmunds criteria for an emotion?
We talked about that at the beginning and there were six criteria.
What are they?
Second,
can you list some supportive evidence that we discussed today?
Uh,
for cultural universality of emotions.
So this idea that emotions are present across all peoples of all cultures from
early on in our evolutionary history.
And third,
can you provide a functional analysis for the six basic emotions we discussed
today?
And if interested,
could you provide the same kind of analysis for jealousy,
which we just touched on as a teaser at the very,
and as usual,
we're going to conclude today with an expert interview.
And again,
this is part of our experts in emotion interview series.
Today we have the pleasure of speaking with Paul Ekman,
who's going to share his perspective on the evolution of emotion and whether
emotions are culturally universal.
So Dr. Paul Ekman is a professor emeritus of psychology at the University of
California San Francisco,
and has authored or edited 13 books most recently as we showed earlier in the
course,
emotions revealed.
Um,
and he's also the coauthor with the Dalai Lama on emotional awareness,
overcoming the obstacles to psychological balance and compassion.
Paul Ekman has consulted with federal and law,
local law enforcement,
national security,
corporate sales and negotiations,
health and education professionals and animators at some of the largest
animations Siri studios in the world.
Some of you might know the show lie to me,
and he was one of the consultants there to sort of teach them how to detect a
facial expressions of emotion being also the founder of the facial action coding
system,
which we talked about earlier in the course.
Um,
Paul Ekman has received countless awards and honors.
Uh,
I couldn't even list all of them today.
Some of them include the distinguished scientific contribution award from the
American psychological association and his work has been discussed in the New
York Times.
Washington Post,
some,
some Smithsonian magazine psychology today,
and the New Yorker Time magazine not surprisingly selected him as one of the
hundred most influential people in 2009.
Um,
he's appeared on numerous sort of media outlets as well for live interviews,
including 48 hours,
dateline.
Good Morning America,
2020 Larry King,
Oprah,
Johnny Carson,
and many other TV programs.
Um,
so it's an honor today to have this amazing experts in emotion interview with
what is perhaps the founder of emotion as we know it today with Dr. Paul Ekman
discussing the topic of our emotions culturally universal.
Thank you again for another great class.